a nuestros espectadores les invitamos a
que sigan ahora con nosotros en directo
a nos vamos hasta Santiago de Chile con
nuestra corresponsal Patricia Luna
porque la isla de rapanui comúnmente
conocida como La isla de Pascua un
incendio causó graves daños a los
famosos moái las estatuas gigantes
sagradas para los aborígenes de La Isla
Pedro edmunds alcalde de rapa nui
denunció que los incendios son
consecuencia de la dejación del Estado
chileno para con la isla Patricia Qué se
sabe sobre este incendio en la isla de
Pascua que además no es el primero que
ocurre en los últimos días Cuáles son
los daños concretos sufridos por los
moai
Pues todavía los datos son preliminares
pero sí sabemos que el incendio comenzó
el lunes que se extendió durante a lo
largo de 100 hectáreas que desacien
hectáreas 60 eran áreas arqueológicas
especialmente el cráter del volcán rano
rakuru donde se tallaron muchas de estas
esculturas que habría un daño Según
dicen las autoridades de en 23 de ellas
y que en un 20% de los casos serían
daños completamente
irreparables se trata de una tragedia
sin precedentes para nuestro patrimonio
en material y natural dijo la delegada
presidencial Juliette Jones que también
afirmó que en este momento en los focos
del incendio se encuentran el incendio
se encuentra controlado aunque aún
todavía habría algunos pocos activos
esto se produce en la isla poco tiempo
después de que volviera a abrir sus
puertas al turismo Esto ocurrió el
pasado 5 de agosto después de dos años
más de dos años sin estar abierta a
recibir turistas debido a la pandemia de
coronavirus y tratando de recuperarse
económicamente una isla que de 163
kilómetros cuadrados pequeñitas situada
a 3.500 kilómetros del océano Pacífico
3.500 kilómetros del continente y que
estaba acostumbrada en tiempos de
turismo a recibir más de 160.000
turistas anuales que sufre ahora un
nuevo batacazo en sus patrimonio
turístico arqueológico y también
cultural por el valor que tienen las los
moáis para los habitantes de la isla y
cómo es Patricia la relación entre la
isla y el gobierno chileno que han
denunciado las autoridades locales
Así es como mencionabas Pedro es el
alcalde de rapa nui denunciaba una vez
más abandono por parte de las
autoridades del gobierno y denunciaba
también cuando va a llegar la ayuda una
vez que el incendio ya culminado porque
este incendio se abría expandido no solo
por Los Fuertes vientos sino porque no
hay bomberos en el lugar solo hay una
pequeña brigada Y entonces habrían sido
pocas las personas que Podrían haber que
habían participado en la extinción en
las labores de extinción junto a los
habitantes de la isla a partir de ahora
el Gobierno ya ha anunciado que va a
enviar una delegación permanente de
bomberos de la corporación nacional
forestal para que no vuelvan a
producirse este tipo de hechos dijeron
también que van a realizar todos los
aprendizajes y se ha abierto también una
investigación para determinar las causas
de este incendio que seguramente está
provocado por el hombre por la quema de
pastizales presumiblemente para que
puedan tomarse y no vuelva a ocurrir
Algo similar en el futuro esto ocurre el
mismo día el que el presidente Gabriel
borich anunció un plan especial contra
incendios y un incremento también en el
presupuesto de esta corporación nacional
para extinguir los incendios se prevé
que va a ser una temporada de incendios
fuerte partido ya afectando severamente
el patrimonio cultural de la isla de
rapa nui que según se afirmó también por
parte de las autoridades podría recibir
alguna financiación por parte de la
UNESCO puesto que es patrimonio de la
humanidad para tratar de restaurar estas
las partes de los moais que puedan ser
recuperables